hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you guys requested ever since uh
uh we did that video uh with stockfish
and chessmaster where stockfish had the
white pieces and the grand master
edition of chess master had the black
pieces i'm not going to do an uh a long
introduction like i already did as we
already paired the 1991 version of chess
master the one from the nintendo
entertainment system uh against this
stock vision we also paired uh the grand
master edition of chess master that was
published in uh 2010
i believe yeah it was 15 years ago
and stockfish won very convincingly with
the white pieces then you guys requested
uh to see what would happen if chess
master uh wielded the white pieces would
the game be any different and would it
be more of a challenge for stallfish for
so for those of you who are just joining
us to check out the first two videos i
made in the series uh as there is quite
a lot explained there now let's check
out the game it is chess master with the
white pieces in chess master opens with
knight to f3 so also chess master goes
for diretti opening i said that even
though uh stockfish wanted to play that
at i forced stockfish to play e4 since
i'm more of an e4 player but uh
chessmaster
obviously needs all the edge that it can
get uh so i allowed the the chess master
to play the rati opening and i did not
interfere in any way whatsoever so
stockfish replies with pawn to d5 we
have d4 now knight to f6 and c4 we have
now uh entered the some sort of a queen
spawn opening uh and here uh ponte e6
stockfish now uh goes into a full queens
gambit decline with pawn to e3 bishop to
e7 and bishop to d3 by chess master d
captures on c4 but bishop captures in
pawn to c4 so this has been played many
many times in uh modern chess uh uh in
the even in the previous years even in
2022 there are there are games that
reach this exact same position we have
castles now uh castles by uh chess
master and c characters on d4 we have e
captures and now there is a game that
was played in 2017 in the world rapid
championship between uh stelios
halachius and georg meyer
that
was won very nicely by uh by george
meyer wielding the black pieces but in
that game castles was played here we
have pawn to a6 and it is now already as
of move eight that we have a completely
new game so of course b5 is coming and
usually you would expect something like
knight to c3 uh knight to e5 and only
after
after pawn to b5 would you move the
bishop but uh
chess master actually does it
preemptively uh so okay knights to c6
and not knight to c3 of course uh the d4
pawn cannot be captured if you go for
this then uh bishop to b5 check and the
black loses the queen
but of course again chess master doesn't
know uh what kind of an opponent he's
playing against so here stockfish just
castles and the bishop to f4
finally b5 by stockfish and now a3
stopping b4 bishop to b7 and now rook to
e1 so now just nicely developing uh both
stockfish and
chess master rook the c8 rook the c1 and
now stockfish says all right
everything is nicely developed it's time
to push b4 so pawn to b4 and
main point i believe is that after eight
captures and knight captures that was
played in the game bishop to b1 is
impossible if you could play bishop to
b1 and keep control of this diagonal
this would be great however it loses a
pawn by force you just capture on f3 and
then pick up the pawn on d4 so that's
why after knight captures on b4 a chess
master has to play bishop to e2 now of
course the bishop captures is made by
bishop captures and the queen keeps
defending the d4 pawn and not just
knight f to d5 just winning some more
squares here improving the position of
the knights and now bishop the g3 again
bishop to d2 is the move you'd expect as
you would control all of these squares
and control the knight on d5 but chess
master uh is just built different as it
would seem and here ponte a5 at some
point stockfish is planning to capture
on c3 so if he can somehow force chess
master to play b captures in c3 this
will be a pass pawn so queen to d2 and
now pawn to h6 taking away the g5 square
from chess master and not knight to a4
chess master says all right i'm gonna
put my knight on c5 and that will be a
monster knight if you ever capture it
i'm gonna play d captures on c5 and have
a beautiful past c pawn
so knight back to f6 with the idea that
if knight comes to c5 uh stockfish can
immediately challenge it with knights to
e4 this would attack the queen and the
knight here and now just rook captures
on c8 this is a necessary
move because if you go for knight to c5
right away uh it doesn't even need
knight d for it actually wins by force
so you just play bishop captures on f3
and you win a piece bishop captures rook
captures in c5 and after rook captures
bishop captures and you cannot recapture
as the queen hangs on d2 so of course um
my chess master spots this place rook
captures on c8 first queen captures and
now rook the c1 with tempo now winning
the c file queen to a8 now grabbing hold
of this diagonal and now preparing to
bring the rook over into the game so
queen to d1 by chess master and now
bishop to c6 you know that the knight is
coming to c5 so you might as well force
it there so knight to c5 and now rook
the c8 we have rooked the c3 uh and now
comes rook back to d8 aligning the rook
nicely with the queen here so queen the
e1 getting out of any future harms away
and now finally stockfish goes for
knight to e4 and here the rook is
attacked the knight is attacked and you
sort of have to trade here so knight
captures an e4 bishop captures an e4 and
now comes bishop the c7
a weird move you you'd expect something
like rook to c7 but chess master's idea
is probably that if rook to c8 then
bishop back to g3 offers a rook trade
and if rook captures then queen captures
of course we are not going to capture
with the pawn and allow stockfish the
past a pawn and here it's a fine
position for both white and black uh
you can play this however uh stockfish
moves the rook back to f8 and now we
have bishop to f1 and this bishop to f1
is basically the the moment of the game
here uh chess master is giving stockfish
a deadly there uh saying that uh okay if
you go from knight to d5 i will
definitely capture with the queen on
on e4 and you will win my rook for two
pieces so is this actually good for
white or good for black stockfish says
well i'm stock fish i can calculate much
better than you uh and stock which
indeed goes for knight to d5 and this is
where uh i believe the
difference in the power of you know just
brute force calculating really comes
into effect so here we have queen
captures on e4 knight captures on c3 and
grand master uh chess master grand
master edition happily trades queens
here captures captures and the b
captures on c3 so chess master won the
two pieces for the rook now has a knight
and the light square bishop for the rook
but stockfish has
a pass pawn and there's already a rook
behind the pass pawn
so what do you do when you have a rook
behind a pass pawn you of course start
pushing a stockfish plays pawn to a4 and
now we have knight to e1 we have pawn to
a3 and knight the c2 pawn to a2 and
adjust the bishop back to f4 so i
believe this is the position that uh
chess master saw when it offered that
trade two pieces for the rook uh as uh
well
most likely chess master was expecting a
one queen and then uh of course you give
up uh one piece rook characters and you
have this position where uh stockfish is
down upon so you have the extra c pawn
that's already a passport you can play
g3 just uh
not get checkmated anytime soon and it's
very hard for for black the uh force uh
uh for forced things here uh
you know
after like some hundred moves will be
played this is most likely winning for
black especially with stockfish wielding
the black pieces but of course you will
still have counter play you have the the
bishop pair you have the pass pawn here
and let's say even if you make one silly
move just c4 and already those spawns
are marching forward however stockfish
did not have this in mind ponte a1
stockfish in fact finds rook to a3 just
going after the c3 pawn and of course
you cannot capture the rook as then
stockfish just brings a queen into the
game so here knight the a1 now blocking
the a1 square rook captures on c3 and
this was a very very important pawn
for the chess master to have
well to have a a game plan basically uh
bishop to d2 attacking the rook now rook
to c6 you do not want to allow the
bishop to come to c4 and pick up the a2
pawn so bishop to e3 we have bishop to
a3 now threatening bishop to b2 and if
this lands then it will be very very
scary so here uh chess master finds pawn
to d5 it's a very nice defensive
resource uh you sacrifice upon you play
bishop b5 bishop a for bishop b3 and you
pick up the a2 pawn so this is what the
chess master finds so e captures on d5
now bishop to b5 with check you don't
have to worry about getting checkmated
your bishop is covering c1 and also you
can always retreat with bishop to f1
even if the rook could somehow deliver a
check so rook to c3
we have bishop to a for continuing with
the plan of bishop b3 bishop captures on
a2 and now just a d4 yeah and now you
have a problem you've moved your bishop
away from this diagonal and you cannot
counter if you capture rook c1 will be
checkmate you have to block this is now
checkmate so after d4 uh bishop to d2 by
chess master and now rook to d3 we have
bishop to e1 and now finally bishop to
b2
and now the problem is uh if you try to
defend this knight to c2 and try and uh
force a1 queen knight captures uh
stockfish has rook to d1 now the d1
square is no longer covered by the
bishop and if king f1 uh trying to not
get checkmated then d3 attacks the
knight knights the e3 attacks the rook
just to rook capture sunny one king
captures a one queen and of course
that's it so after this bishop to beat
you move bishop to b3 stockfish uh uh
has to allow this uh saudi a two pawn
will be captured but stockfish now has
other plans bishop captures on a1 bishop
character sun a2 and now rook to d1 and
it seems like it's still playable you
still have the bishop pair against the
bishop and rook
but it only seems that way the problem
is if king to f1 trying to defend your
bishop d3 stops the king from going to
e2 and once you play anything let's say
bishop b3 the rook will just move
there's really no defense against pawn
to d2 whatever you play pawn to d2 is
coming and here that chess master can
resign so here there is no way of
stopping rook captures on e1 so
basically you only uh
your only option is not to get
checkmated so d3 stockfish playing it
cool not even capturing the bishop right
away king f2 now bishop to d4 with check
king of three and only now rook captures
an e1 so now the bishop will have to be
given away for the pawn but now of
course everyone realizes that stockfish
is easily winning this we have bishop
the a4 and rooked
uh a1 queen bishop captures and rook
captures on d1 and now stockfish is just
up two pieces of bishop and the rook and
uh it would be pointless to show you
uh how the game ends but stockfish even
makes um
fun out of this position so i will show
it king to e2 rook to h1 going after the
pawns h3 rook to g1 goes after this pawn
king of three defending rook f1 check
king to e4 and now bishop to b6 we have
g3 trying to save those pawns for as
long as possible h rook to h1 pawn to h4
and now comes
ponte h5 not allowing the pawns to
advance any further king f3 now rook to
g1 and the king can no longer keep an
eye on the g3 pawn so came to e4 and now
rook captures on g3 king to d5 and now
it's actually a forced checkmate in 10
and stockfish of course finds it rook to
c3 uh we have pawn to f5 now bishop to
d8 now stockfish is planning bishop to
f6 and this will keep the white king
locked in uh in this tiny square uh so
king to d4 bishop to f6 check king to e4
and now bishop captures an h4 king back
to e5 bishop to f6 check king to e4 and
now just h4 now this pawn is becoming a
queen and that's basically it king d5 h3
king to d6 h2 king to d7 and now h1
queen and it doesn't matter where a
chess master goes if king here then
queen to d1 is checkmate so chess master
played king to e8 and of course
stockfish delivered queen to c6
checkmate and uh it is uh uh only as of
six move 68 uh that uh chess master was
was bested uh so it was uh quite an
impressive game i would say a much
better one than when uh chess master had
the black pieces uh but still i mean it
was uh sort of a an equal game uh
you know the opening was okay the middle
game was okay but as soon as uh as soon
as the moment um uh came where uh chess
master tried to out calculate stockfish
when uh this um uh basically when knight
the d5 was played uh or rather even when
bishop to f1 was played and allowed
knights to d5 uh this is where we knew
that uh stockfish would just you know
have a brilliant brilliant game and i
believe it all came down to this uh
point where uh here uh a chess master
was kind of considering maybe uh uh
pawn to a1 uh but stock was just you
know completely uh crushed the position
with rook to e3 uh so yeah chess master
really uh played well uh played the
opening uh you know just like a modern
engine maybe a few more aggressive lines
than a modern engine would choose but
then
it all came down basically to how well
you can calculate and no one calculates
as well as as stockfish until the next
version of stockfish or until they power
up alpha zero again or uh you know uh
until lee leches zero plays some sort of
a brilliant brilliant game so there are
some very very impressive games amongst
the modern engines but you know most of
the time the nnue stockfish does usually
reign supreme uh nice nice try by our
good friend the chess master it was
quite an interesting game so i hope you
guys enjoyed it we tried to give chess
master justice giving it the white
pieces but it was not enough to take
down stockfish
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said if you want a bit
more history about chess master about
this match that we've organized do check
out the previous two videos both links
will be in the description below so
check that out as well i would like to
thank uh john uh shirtless keith tester
and gabriel rodriguez evan sterling and
john austin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day